el ex ceni se refiere a él como el ex vicepresidente
Dick Cheney de George Bush fue detenido
cargo como silla de conferencia
del partido republicano un carguero Enel
que si impulso tiene la agenda política del
partido republicano en el congreso
oposición a este fraude
circunscripción que estabas encontrando, argumentó
no la señalización solo la
responsabilidad del ex presidente del 6
luego hubo un caso especifico de los negros
fiesta la retina ra del jefe y el voto
al revés y cheney muestra el
influencia a la que mantiene con más sobre
el congresista republicano para enviar
pero piensa es que no puedes tener
ninguna oposición es el ex diputado
presidente culo al ex presidente prodon
amanecer de la guerra que como dice mario solo
en cannes en washington si guardas eso
mantener el apoyo al expresidente
para asegurar la victoria y el
selección del culo de sla tv de 2022
traducir votar reunirse con ellos cena
este verano dv que para ganar la
selección sin embargo hicker e
conócenos en error corrigiéndolo
si, en definitiva, se trata de los graneros las
proxima electoral por favor que no se puede
apoya mucho el mismo tiempo
mentes de cómo comienza el fraude electoral
quien argumentó los cambios en el
constitución de lo que fui en las noticias
Necesito un partido republicano fuerte
lo cual le dara toro lo mas posible para evitar eso
Donald Trump Jaeggy en la Casa Blanca
de nuevo